so wie fast alle um die glashäuser
fertig gemacht so schön wir mussten
werden und die teppiche noch angucken
flecken es weg da passiert wir neu aus
das ist sehr schön gemacht gefällt mir
sehr gut das ist schon freut mich also
wir haben wir jetzt die ganze position
angeguckt position als graffiti
entfernung position zwei
fassadenreinigung haben wir ja auch
kontrolliert glasreinigung haben wir ja
auch kontrolliert teppich shampoo niveau
haben wir jetzt auch kontrolle brauche
ich noch heute noch ein autogramm
ja natürlich vielen dank mussten wir
noch einen termin vereinbaren wie die
glasreinigung ja ich denke vierzehnter
achter am montag wird nun werden kein
problem hatten wir festhalten so fest ab
sofort bis 14.8 dahinter schon tag nach